e aí
e qual é o ingrediente essencial para
uma boa receita eu sou filha e neta de
cozinheiras de mão cheia a cozinha
sempre foi o coração da casa e comida
sinônimo de afeto logo o principal
ingrediente é o amor
é mas ao longo da minha jornada pessoal
e profissional eu pude expandir o
conceito desse amor e manifestar esse
amor dentro e fora da cozinha de maneira
mais holística e empática a partir de
escolhas alimentares mais conscientes em
2006 quando eu saí da casa dos meus pais
recém-formada em jornalismo e uma
mochila recheada de sonhos eu buscava
uma vida simples em contato com a
natureza focada no autoconhecimento e na
espiritualidade
e eu nunca sonhei em ser empreendedora e
ter uma fábrica de alimentos naquela
época o mundo dos negócios me parecia
bem distante dos meus ideais esse estilo
de vida natureba meio hip bicho do mato
para mim não combinava com o perfil de
uma empresária
e o meu primeiro emprego logo que eu saí
de casa foi numa ong conservacionista do
cerrado lá durante um ano eu pude
pesquisar e conhecer de perto a grande
biodiversidade do cerrado e as
constantes ameaças que ele vem sofrendo
por conta dos avanços das monoculturas
de soja de milho e da pecuária na região
e nessa ong eu pude participar de
projetos de permacultura de agrofloresta
e de agricultura orgânica todos que
trabalhavam lá comiam juntos no
refeitório eram verdadeiros banquetes
vegetarianos coloridos nutritivos e
muito saborosos
é para mim uma jovem gaúcha recém-saída
de porto alegre foram duas grandes
descobertas a primeira saber que o
cerrado era muito mais do que aquelas
árvores secas e retorcidas que eu tinha
aprendido na escola e a segunda saber
que alimentação vegetariana além de
nutritiva e muito gostosa também era
mais ecológica pois ajudava promover a
biodiversidade dentro e fora do prato
e se eu gostava tanto de tomar banho de
cachoeira em água pura e cristalina para
mim já não fazia mais sentido me
alimentar de uma indústria que gasta
mais de 15 mil litros de água para fazer
1 kg de carne e que transforma a
biodiversidade da amazônia e do cerrado
impacto depois dessa experiência na ong
eu fui morar no mosteiro zen budista na
califórnia
é nesse mosteiro além de uma imersão na
prática do zen budismo eu tive a minha
primeira experiência profissional na
culinária eu coloquei a mão na massa
mesmo e fui responsável por servir as
três refeições diárias e foi nesse
mosteiro que eu descobri que a culinária
além de mais amorosa e mais ecológica
também poderia se transformar em uma
prática de meditação
e a cozinha do mosteiro ficava muito
próxima a sala de meditação então eu
tinha que cozinhar em silêncio atenta
para fazer o mínimo de barulho possível
imagina o pessoal lá meditando e eu
batendo tampa de panela derrubando
alguma coisa no chão ou até mesmo
abrindo a torneira muito forte não
definitivamente isso não podia acontecer
a qualidade da minha atenção e presença
em cada momento eram fundamentais ali
naquela cozinha e a partir daí eu
comecei a unir essas quatro experiências
amor natureza
a meditação e alimentação
é com estas conexões e com um olhar mais
consciente e ecológico de mim e do todo
a minha volta o meu prato de comida se
tornou um grande portal para muitos
outros ensinamentos um deles é a
interdependência essa teia de relações
inter conectadas dinâmicas e integradas
que é a vida
e por exemplo quando você está no
restaurante com cardápio na mão ou
naquele bicho é maravilhoso cheio de
opções o que motiva as suas escolhas as
cores os sabores os nutrientes a dieta
da moda ou você consegue ampliar sua
visão e incluir naquele prato quem
plantou quem colheu quem preparou aquele
alimento ajuda a sustentar um pequeno
produtor local ou uma grande
multinacional ou ainda indo mais a fundo
olhando para o seu prato de comida você
consegue incluir ali o calor do sol
com as chuvas os ventos as queimadas na
amazônia a qualidade do solo a interação
dos microrganismos das bactérias toda
teia da vida que faz parte daquela
refeição e que contribuiu para que
aquele alimento chegasse até você
e isso é interdependência nada existe
isoladamente não existe proteger a
natureza nós somos natureza nós somos a
amazônia eo cerrado queimando a nossa
saúde individual depende da saúde de
todas essas relações que envolvem
humanos não-humanos e o planeta como um
todo
e no mundo de alimentos ultraprocessados
e embalados onde a maioria dos
ingredientes considerados normais numa
dieta padrão nos levam uma total diz
conexão de nós mesmos da terra e do
cosmos uma abordagem integrativa da
alimentação é necessária
é a maneira como nos alimentamos impacta
diretamente os recursos naturais do
planeta contribuindo para o aquecimento
global mudanças climáticas poluição do
ar da água do solo extinção de espécies
supressão de florestas sem contar na
quantidade de lixo de agrotóxicos e de
desperdício de comida nesse sentido o
cenário não está muito animadora
nós estamos no vermelho nosso orçamento
ambiental estourou a um mês peso do dia
vinte e nove de julho estamos consumindo
mais recursos naturais do que a terra
capaz de regenerar em um ano
é isso quer dizer que de agora até o
final do ano estaremos consumindo
recursos naturais das gerações futuras
é mas eu tenho duas filhas eu quero
mudar essa realidade eu quero estou
trabalhando para deixar um planeta
melhor para as minhas filhas e a partir
da educação da elas também deixar seres
humanos melhores para o planeta
a e é por isso que eu tenho uma notícia
muito gostosa para dar para vocês
e nós podemos começar a tirar o planeta
do vermelho de forma prazerosa cheia de
propósito e significado
e eu acredito que podemos mudar o mundo
em nossa próxima refeição a partir de
escolhas alimentares mais conscientes
menos destrutivas e igualmente saborosas
bom e foi com a vontade de contribuir
para essa nova era que alimentação se
tornou para mim também um bom negócio um
bom investimento em 2013 depois de
outras aventuras mundo afora eu voltei
para o cerrado e junto com thiago meu
sócio nós fundamos uma fábrica de creme
de castanhas na chapada dos veadeiros
é muito mais do que um plano de negócios
detalhado a nossa vontade sempre foi de
compartilhar um estilo de vida autêntico
e alimentos naturais de verdade aqueles
que a gente queria consumir na nossa
casa oferecer para as nossas filhas
amigos e comunidade desde a fundação nós
temos um propósito muito claro que a
contribuir para um sistema alimentar
regenerativo onde a medida do nosso
sucesso não está apenas no lucro e sim
no impacto positivo que temos a
capacidade de gerar ao longo de toda a
cadeia produtiva cuidando de nós da
terra e de todos os envolvidos e como
que a gente faz isso como que a gente
consegue unir amor natureza
autoconhecimento alimentar
o e empreendedorismo
e nós priorizamos ingredientes locais
dos biomas brasileiros e valorizamos os
pequenos produtores nossa produção é
artesanal em pequena escala e moinhos de
pedra
e nós somos naturais de verdade nada de
corantes conservantes ou aditivos
artificiais de nomes estranhos
valorizamos a simplicidade menos é mais
pouco açúcar poucos ingredientes a
natureza é perfeita promovemos uma
alimentação baseada em plantas
e evitamos o uso de plástico e
participamos de programas de reciclagem
investimos em qualidade de vida
qualidade nas relações humanas e com o
ambiente acreditamos na colaboração e
união entre propósitos pessoas e
empresas
e vocês pode achar que eu sou uma
sonhadora mas felizmente eu não estou
sozinha nessa nesses últimos seis anos
nesse processo de empreender eu pude
descobrir que a questão ambiental veio
para ficar não se trata mais de
preocupação de um pequeno grupo de
naturebas ou coisa de vegano e sim uma
questão de sobrevivência dentro e fora
dos negócios e nesse sentido os sinais
dos novos tempos já são evidentes
alimentos que tem saúde e
sustentabilidade ocupam 4 das 10
principais tendências no ramo de
alimentação e bebidas destaque aqui para
alimentação plantese baseada em plantas
que ocupa a segunda posição e aqui no
brasil seguimos nesse mesmo movimento 14
por cento da população brasileira já se
declara
oi e o brasil ocupa o quarto lugar no
ranking global de consumo de alimentos
saudáveis
em diante desses números já podemos
observar uma nova relação entre empresas
e consumidores os consumidores estão
cada vez mais conscientes e não consomem
mais apenas bens ou serviços consomem
causas e valorizam propósitos para um
bem maior não se trata mais de modismo
de tendência ou de um pequeno nicho de
mercado e sim uma mudança de hábitos
necessária para a regeneração da vida no
planeta eu acredito que as empresas
podem e devem contribuir para uma nova
era de abundância mais próspera mais
ecológica e mais amorosa
e qual é o principal ingrediente para
uma boa receita ou para um bom negócio
eu sigo confiante que esse ingrediente é
o amor que possamos manifestar esse
grande amor em cada pequena escolha
diária reconhecendo e reverenciando a
terra como fonte de conexão como fonte
de nutrição como fonte da vida investir
no planeta definitivamente faz bem para
qualquer negócio muito obrigada
e aí